okay so as you guys know I'm always
sitting down with guests hearing what
they hear about things but a lot of
times you guys were asked me what do I
think about things I get some of it
across in in the show a lot of it across
on Twitter but what we thought we'd do
some quick videos on what I think about
some of the hot issues of the day and
you guys are always asking me about the
2016 election believe it or not we have
11 more months of this thing I feel like
we've been doing this for five years
already and some of these guys have been
running their whole lives but yes the
election is coming let's talk about the
Democrats first because there's really
only two of them right sorry Martin
O'Malley it's not going to happen this
time you've got Bernie and we got
Hillary so Bernie quick as I've said
many times before I really like Bernie I
think he's talking about the right
things I think money in politics may be
the biggest problem we have in America
because everything stems from that right
because we have our warped system I
think talking about the the ninety-nine
percent and the one percent is big I
have mentioned many times before that
really when they talk about the one
percent in a lot of holes it looks like
the one percent around four hundred
grand a year at four hundred grand a
year yeah you're doing well you're doing
better than me but you know what it's is
that you're not pulling strings right at
four hundred grand a year you're not
even pulling strings at five million a
year when we talk about the one percent
what we really should be talking about
is the point one percent people with
hundreds of millions of dollars and
billions of dollars that are just
pouring money into the system right and
the horrible Supreme Court decision that
allowed them to do this so I think
Bernie basically is talking about the
right things you know free college stuff
like that I hope we can pay for it but
within what I can understand about a
candidate I do like him I do fear that a
socialist from north from New Hampshire
a lot of people are not going to get on
board with that especially people in the
middle of the country and you know
there's only a couple states that really
matter because we know the way the map
works out so it always at this point
basically comes down to florida ohio
colorado Pennsylvania and I'm not sure
that that he can pull all those of
course he'd have to beat Hillary in a
primary to get there so we shall see
Hillary yeah this has been a pretty
uninspiring campaign as a general rule I
like her better than the Republicans I
think she's at her best when she's being
attacked so like in the Benghazi hearing
I think she was good I think she's been
pretty
in the in the debates but you know her
husband was president and george w
bush's dad was president and i was
brother wants to be president we left
England so that we wouldn't have to have
families that ruled over us for forever
that's a big strike against her in my
book I do think you know breaking that
glass ceiling would be nice and I
basically think she's a decent person so
I really do hate it when when people on
the left on the far left especially are
framing that she's a neocon and she's
exactly like the Republicans it's just
silly I do have a sense that she
understands the way government works and
is trying to make things better but I
don't love her by any stretch I know
people are gonna be angry at me on that
one as Republicans they're all pretty
terrible right they just all are pretty
terrible I've watched the debates
they're ridiculous you know Trump look
Trump has this thing so mixed up has
everyone so defensive and so crazed that
we can't really get a sense of who the
real candidates are right Bush has been
terrible I mean absolutely terrible I
feel like they've got like a gun behind
him and they're like you're running for
president whether you like it or not and
he does not like it I think he's pretty
uninspiring right Trump is just it's
over the top and ridiculous who the hell
knows right nobody knows what to do
about that Kasich yeah you know he's
basically okay is he gonna be President
probably not Carly Fiorina is she gonna
be President probably not I think it
would be interesting just to watch her
debate with Hillary two really strong
women but that wouldn't make me vote for
anyone certainly um who else you got I
think Marco Rubio even though I strongly
disagree with him on some of the
religious stuff and when he talks about
abortion I think at least he's in the
right line of work you know I think he
has a compelling story his growing up
and you know children of immigrants and
all that stuff but yeah he's a little
too rehearsed and all that and I hate to
make it about the theatrics of
television but I think he's at least
somebody that should be a politician I
suppose who else ben Carson I mean Ben
Carson's not going to be present he
should be a neurosurgeon that's that's a
specific job and that's a pretty good
job and he should probably stick to that
so I don't know who to support at any of
these guys what I would like to see in
general is that if we could
talk about the ideas more instead of
just the day-to-day this person said
that thing and this person and gotcha
this and you know the debates have been
pretty bad i think the moderators have
been pretty bad so i would like to see
more big idea stuff let's really talk
about what role government should have
let's talk about really what are the
ways that we can make the economy work
better what are the ways that the tax
system can be fair you know all of this
stuff but unfortunately get caught in
all this nonsense so look I love talking
about it I love thinking about it and
we're going to keep going and we'll see
how ridiculous it gets all right
you